[Musique]
l'espagne produit chaque année 5
millions de tonnes de porc et compte
plus de 2000 très vastes exploitations
porcines la région de castille et leon à
elle seule en concentre environ 500
aujourd'hui ce modèle économique est au
centre d'une virulente bataille
politique raquel condé est l'une des
rares propriétaires de maquereaux ferme
à ouvrir ses portes à la presse
ici nous élevons 8000 port et nous avons
mille mère reproductrice et pour le rire
à chaque année près de 30000 port
naissent dans cette exploitation vingt
personnes travaillent ici à temps
complet l'activité porcine est un
important pourvoyeur d'emplois dans la
région
bonjour roberto qu'est ce que vous
faites on déplace les trucs qui vont
mettre bas très bien allons
l'élevage de raquel rempli les critères
qui exige le label espagnol aenor animal
welfare il est basé sur les référentiels
européen de bien-être animal
dans cette grange il y à 338 et comme
vous pouvez le voir elles ont de
l'espace elles peuvent bouger se coucher
et ont même des jouets pour s'amuser
vous voyez nous respectons les normes de
bien être animal les animaux ne sont pas
stressés ils ne nous fuit pas car ce
sont des animaux bien traités
alors développé dans les années soixante
dix pour fournir au plus grand nombre
une viande à bas prix le modèle
d'élevage intensif est aujourd'hui en
espagne de plus en plus contesté
essentiellement pour son impact sur
l'environnement
qu'espère quand on dit que nous ne
respectons pas l'environnement et bien
comme vous avez pu le voir nous avons
installé des panneaux solaires des
tétines pour ne pas gaspiller l'eau
lorsque les cochons boivent des bouées
pour contrôler le niveau de l'eau nous
sommes plus que dépendant de notre
environnement masculin
mais ceux qui concentrent le plus de
critiques c'est le lisier contenu dans
ces fosses utilisés par les agriculteurs
comme fertilisant naturel
il provoque des pollutions de la nappe
phréatique par les nitrates on
va les mesures et l'eau du puits
dans la région la qualité de l'eau des
puits est devenu un problème
je vais préparer l'appareil
emilia vit dans un petit village situé
non loin de deux exploitations porcines
ça y est je lai une fois tous les deux
mois elles mesurent le taux de nitrates
dans l'eau à qui vous voyez on est à 80
mg cette eau n'est pas potable on ne
peut pas cuisiner avec non plus tout ce
qu'on peut faire à la rigueur celle
utilisée pour arroser les plantes lieu
fixe à 50 mg par litre la concentration
maximale de nitrates pouvant être
présents dans l'eau au delà elle n'est
plus potable emilie a fait partie d'un
programme de contrôles mis en place par
greenpeace elle est chargée d'effectuer
des mesures chez les habitants mais sa
mission est devenu de plus en plus
difficile
nous avions commencé les mesures dans
certains villages mais du jour au
lendemain les gens ne voulaient plus
entendre parler de nous
parce que eh bien il semblerait qu'ils
ont reçu des menaces du genre si tu
parles on brûle ton tracteurs on coupe
les arbres de ton verger tout ce qui
peut nuire en fait
la polémique autour des macros ferme est
devenu en espagne un enjeu politique le
parti populaire de droite défend leur
utilité économique alors que le parti
socialiste au pouvoir veut les limiter
au maximum
demander leur avis aux espagnols qui
souffrent de la pollution des sols de
l'eau et des odeurs et qui aujourd'hui
quittent leur village alors qu'ils
subissent déjà les effets de la
dépopulation
[Applaudissements]
cette marche de contestation dans la
campagne à côté de valladolid s'oppose à
la construction d'une vaste exploitation
porcine à trois kilomètres du centre du
village
si on installe l'exploitation ici elle
sera à seulement 200 mètres de la
rivière ils disent que les arbres
freineront les odeurs et les gaz
toxiques que la montagne est une
barrière naturelle mais c'est un non
sens total
pour ce maire socialiste les impacts de
l'installation d'une macro ferme seront
bien plus négatif que positif
les gens viennent à cabezon parce qu'ils
aiment la campagne les paysages et cette
installation va tout simplement faire
perdre à la commune toute son
attractivité
pire encore ceux qui vivent ici vont
s'en aller
aux alentours il y à la route du vin de
cigales s qui associe de nombreuses
entreprises et génère beaucoup de
tourisme ça va aussi désaffectée
pour apaiser les tensions certaines
régions revoient leur politique agricole
la castille la manche par exemple a
décidé de geler toutes les demandes
d'installation de nouvelles
exploitations de plus de deux mille
têtes et cela jusqu'en 2025